hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen bio ich hoffe natürlich
jedes gut yaman ich habe bock alter wir
haben gerade freitagabend 20 uhr
wochenende die kann man am wochenende
besser starten als und organisationen
mit dem boxen direkt aus dem laden zu
öffnen habe ich noch nie gemacht also
wirklich aber ich muss sagen leute
freitagabend ne sonst trinke ich auch
eher selten ein bierchen aber hassen zu
diesem freitagabend und diesen tollen
mistel boxen kann man sich doch denke
ich meinen büchern hier genehmigen dann
macht das gleich noch viel mehr spaß
sowie partymäßig der preis auf saturn
köln spaß
nein
die arme mac tastatur tschuldigung
stichwort köln ich war gestern in köln
unterwegs und brachte mir spontan auf
dem rückweg zum bahnhof ich bin im zug
gefahren tech mal kurz hier den saturn
ab vielleicht haben die am mystery
boxmeer ich wollte das immer schon mal
machen ende laden zu gehen da kann ich
mir leid welche aussuchen kann die
abwägen welches schwer welches nicht
schwer und das habe ich gemacht ich habe
viel mitgenommen ich hätte auch gerne
noch mehr mitgenommen aber die konnte
ich nicht transportieren die am ende die
tüte reingepasst ihr könnt hier sehr
gern mal sehen oder wollen wir noch mal
schauen
das problem ist doch ich bin mit dem zug
ich kann eigentlich gar nicht so viel
transportiert 70 euro bisher noch mehr
70 euro 40 euro alles hält die hier sind
jetzt im büro ist dann hätte ich bin
jetzt mittlerweile im zug und es geht
nach hause alltag auch so dumm dass ich
heute aus dem zug fahren obwohl ich
wusste ich will nach diesen box
zuschauen und jetzt hier live band jetzt
kann schwegler auf jeden fall ich stand
gerade aus ihrem wahlkreis mit der tüte
aber einmal kommen sondern schaffen dazu
mir mein zug und hast du wieder was zum
ausbacken gefunden und er meinte sogar
dass er mal wegen mir so etwas gekauft
hat also falls das schöne grüße genau
und davon machen wir jetzt eine nach der
anderen auch ich würde sagen wir starten
mit der günstigsten die addiert sich
euro gekostet so das ist nochmal anderes
feeling wenn man sich die selber
ausgesucht hat 440 euro und die habe ich
mitgenommen weil die iren schwer ist
also zumindest im vergleich zu den
anderen und hier steht drauf die box
enthält ware von einem ursprünglichen
verkaufspreis von mindestens 80 euro das
heißt genau 40 irgendwie zahl und hier
muss mindestens 80 euro drin sein hab
jetzt nicht so die mega hoffnung dass
wir was krasses drin haben wo ich bin
mal gespannt ob man sagen kann dass sich
die boxen aus dem saturn in köln lohnen
werden also nicht lang schnacken eine
sache die ihr euch sagen kann auf meinem
zweiten kanal der ist einfach nur txtr
com aktuell und das geht auch erstmal
noch weiter jeden tag wurde videos zum
thema restposten mystery boxen an box
links und so weiter im chapter gerne
rein wenn ihr euch dafür interessiert
auch hier steht ja direkt schon drauf
was da alles drin ist das wollen wir gar
nicht wissen naja mal schauen übrigens
meinte der saturn mitarbeiter war ich
habe gefragt habt ihr auch teure boxen
das teuerste ist nämlich leider nur 70
euro also dass ich bezahlt habe er
meinte zu mir das wird jeden tag neu
aufgefüllt aber mehr als 100 euro kostet
so eine box eigentlich nie bisher weg
als erstes haben wir hier medisana
fieberthermometer dann haben wir hier
ein intense lämmlein super speed usb 3
bringen diese scheiß kabel nur bei den
könnte ich kotzen noch ein kabel was ist
das für ein hdmi-kabel dann haben wir
hier eine handy hülle fürs huawei y 6 p
also die kann ich eigentlich direkt im
müll schmeißen einen wegschmeißen
natürlich nicht aber die kann ich
höchstens verschenken und hier haben wir
eine usb webcam hd webcam mit 960 räumen
der aktuellen zeit mit corona alter
moment mal und wieso haben wir hier ein
langes haar in dieser kiste anders sehen
also das war hier mit dem karl ist das
im preis mit drin weil auf die 80 euro
komme ich sicherlich mit dem schrott
hier nicht ist das h 40 euro wert oder
was mein gott 80 euro sagen die mir also
jetzt geht es aber los ich bin mal
gespannt also es ist ja also die kamera
kostet bei ebay 44 99 das ist schon mal
ganz gut also habe ich quasi wenn ich
die verkaufe den preis wieder raus wenn
ich die wirklich verkaufen sollte
theoretisch dann haben wir hier noch den
usb stick für 8 euro 50 und haben wir
hier dieses geniale fieberthermometer 8
eur 88 und hier dieses hyper lange kabel
wohl leider keinen code trockels
deswegen kann ich es auch nicht
einscannen und hier haben wir noch ein
kabel für 93 erwarten wir aber ich komme
doch da gar nicht auf 80 euro was das
denn mindestens 80 euro sagen die mich
glaube ich dass es geht los batterien
bei gut startet nicht optimal wir machen
wir weiter mit einer box die ich hier
gekauft habe gesetzt auch was wir da
drin sein ich habe also hier müssen
jetzt mindestens 120 euro wir starten
wieder super rein mit einem kabel weiter
geht's mit das kann man ins auto ans
armaturenbrett kleben und kann er das
handy dran passen dann haben wir hier
schon weg ok oh ja wir gucken wir doch
direkt am rhein oder was das hier ist
beim bäcker dingen kannst du am strom
anschließen und dann okay es ist doch
kein bäcker ist es ein thermometer um
gesteht 77 euro dran vorderleute 77 euro
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie viel das
noch wert ist weil ich mir sicher 77
euro kriegt dafür nicht und das teil war
glaube ich auch schon mal aus sagt es
ist sogar aus dem jahr 2016 das heißt
nichts gutes ok erstens es ist ein
thermometer und zweitens ist das hier
glaube ich die alte variante von dem was
mir hier angezeigt wird naja was solls
weiter geht es mit wlan repeater von
tp-link hier steht auch wieder der preis
3 53 eur 990 und der wird mir hier bei
ebay sogar für 89 euro angezeigt das ist
nicht verkehrt sonst haben wir nur trash
drin denkmal die kann ich gebrauchen
eine sd-karte noch dazu mit 128 gb dann
haben wir die nächste smartphone hülle
und hirn oder so ein quatsch oder kfz
dingen und auch nicht wirklich was und
fieberthermometer nummer zwei halt
hierzu muss ich sagen zweite box 60 euro
hat sich gelohnt also safe so da kann
man sich einiges an gewinnen rausholen
wenn man es wirklich alles verkauft
haben nach oben aber weiter geht es mit
der nächsten wir haben nämlich eine für
sage und schreibe
70 euro das schlitzen einmal unten
drunter her und hier auch noch nen
sd-karte 32 gb jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob ich noch besser wird als die
davor
[Musik]
nichts regt mich mehr auf als paul banks
und kabel diesen scheiß boxenmauer bank
hc 15.000 vielen dank dreier immerhin 80
stunden das ist eine gute bank die
crystal vielleicht für 30 euro los aber
hier muss ja einen warenwert von
mindestens 140 euro sap drin sein weiter
geht es mit dem fahrrad tacho motivation
für mich um wieder mehr auf meinen
drahtesel zu steigen weiter gehts mit
dem zweiten kaka das nächste handy case
diesmal ebenfalls wieder für das huawei
y 6 p dann haben wir hier noch ein
fieberthermometer wie viele also die mit
dem fieberthermometer in warte mal kurz
wollen mich verarschen dann haben wir
noch stifte und hier ein kabel das war
es einfach eine knopfbatterien ist es
euer ernst ist hier oder was wie soll
ich denn damit auf 140 euro kommen also
da muss ich jetzt mal kurz einmal hier
die einzigen produkte hier drin liegen
bisschen wert haben ist der tacho und
die power band aber das wird ja nicht so
krass fiel sein also da bin ich jetzt
mal gespannt also powerplay kostet 29 90
dann musste er jetzt 100 euro kosten
also damit kenne ich mich nicht aus aber
vielleicht wird das ja tatsächlich so
sein garmin edge 130 krass alter damit
hätte ich jetzt gar nicht gerecht und
hey wieso ist so ein kleiner tacho so
packen teuer also ich hatte früher auch
mal ein paar tage aber der kommt nicht
einfach hier 150 bis 190 euro ergibt ein
so viel geld dafür aus naja gut kann er
egal sein dann muss ich sagen hat die
box natürlich doch ihren wert allein
damit und hier mit der bank komme ich da
so auf 150 bis 180 euro wenn nichts
verkaufen natürlich muss ich auch
erstmal kunden finden aber bei den
ganzen deutschen fahrradrennen ist das
sicherlich eine schnelle nummer wenn
hans jürgen mit frau b nämlich schon ein
bisschen zu auf durch deutschland
getourt ist mit seinem drahtesel und
sein terror kaputt geht dann komme ich
ins spiel ok weiter geht's mit der
letzten mal gespannt ob die noch besser
ist eigentlich würde ich sagen haben wir
uns fast von boxee box zimmer gesteigert
fieberthermometer erstmal ein usb stick
fieberthermometer nummer 38 leute wenn
ich fiebere habt dann kann ich mir ab
jetzt 171 in die zunge oder unter die
zunge und 1 macht man das noch unter die
achsel genau und dann kann ich immer
genau bestimmt wieviel gerade ich jetzt
fieberhaft weiter geht es mit das ist
gut das ist bestimmt auch gar nicht so
günstig werden eine kuh journalistik
gaming mary so weiter geht es mit diesem
baking
bluetooth-adapter dankeschön dann haben
wir natürlich werde das gedacht noch
eine handy hülle das ist dann auch immer
ein bisschen los sicherlich weil jeder
täglich davon aus dass da jetzt jemand
kommt und einfach alle boxen mit nimmt
sondern dass ein kunde eine box mit
nimmt und dann ist es auch scheißegal ob
die jetzt überall halten
fieberthermometer reintun oder nicht
weil pro person im durchschnitt
wahrscheinlich eh nur eine box weg geht
die wusste ja nicht dass youtube alex li
vorbeikommt so dann haben wir hier nur
fritz samt kosten bestimmt auf 30 euro
kann ich mir vorstellen medisana masken
und zu guter letzt das muss jetzt ein
bisschen teurer sein denkt papier
karten
was ist das denn ach so ja das ist so
ein bisschen dickeres papierform
einladungen zu gestalten dann bin ich
jetzt nicht so überzeugt von dachte erst
das wäre ein prospekt dann wäre was los
gewesen das sag ich euch mir schauen wir
nach also dass hier kann wert haben
zumindest einen kleinen wert dieses ding
auf und liegt dass hier eventuell kommt
start nochmal hier möchte ich denke das
kostet nicht viel na gut immerhin 20
euro bei saturn und jetzt schauen wir
mal hier die lampe uns an ungefähr
richtig eigentlich 5 zwischen 30 und 40
euro und dieses ding muss eigentlich
dann wieder 100 euro kosten sonst ist
hier irrt foul 74 eur 990 nur das ist
nicht so gut also damit komme ich ja
niemals auf mindestens 140 euro naja ich
muss sagen hat auf jeden fall spaß
gemacht das ganze zu öffnen aber da war
keine box dabei wo ich sagen würde okay
das hat sich mega gelohnt wenn man das
verkauft dann macht man da richtig plus
also das wird über echt schwer vor allem
die erste und die letzte waren schon
echten flotte hat sich saturn auf jeden
fall gefreut dass ich dir gekauft hat
naja leute danke fürs zuschauen lassen
wir gerne daumen nach oben da bin ich
auch das gleiche und media markt machen
soll in zukunft ansonsten steckt auf
jeden fall mein anderer kontakt und wir
sehen uns heute nicht wieder und jetzt
sehr in den kanal haut rein